i had this rule with my old man and i
have it with my son which is when you're
fishing you can swear
and so we're out fishing he catches a
fish and i'm trying to get him to take a
picture with the fish before we let it
go and it flops out of his hands and and
these bass have these little spines on
on their back and the fin pokes them in
the hand falls in the water he starts to
cry
and he's like oh
and i said hey buddy are you all right
you all right he said oh
dad i'm about to swear
hey you know you know the rules and he
goes that bass that bass is stupid
because well you know i think we say hey
don't say someone call someone stupid
that's bad you shouldn't say that and i
s and he continues to christ
did you feel better he said a little bit
stupid stupid bass and i was like i was
like
all right buddy yeah you know now's the
time get it out and he goes
that stupid bass is a [__] [__]
[Applause]